There's no better hero to love than a super-powered
one, so it makes sense that every year sees
more comic book blockbusters hit the screen
- and bring even more incredible mistakes
and errors along with them.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Biggest Mistakes
in Superhero Movies.
Guardians of the Galaxy
The tears started flowing when Star Lord read
his mother's last goodbye, but when filming
the scene, Chris Pratt actually got to hear
a recording of the lines - recorded that day.
The prop was already made, which means the
goodbye note and the voiceover don't match
up.
A big mistake any speed-reading fan would
catch.
Captain America: The Winter Soldier
The directors wasted no time in showing how
effective Cap had become in the modern era,
taking down a ship full of enemies almost
singlehandedly.
Even if he's able to jump from an airplane
into the ocean without injury, the fact that
he emerges completely dry is going a bit too
far.
Considering how grounded the rest of the movie
was, it's a ridiculous oversight.
Once the movie's villain reveals himself,
things spin out of control fast.
Things go from bad to worse when Cap gets
tossed into a city bus, which flips when it's
struck by another vehicle.
It's an impressive stunt, but when you take
a closer look at the massive crash, and the
lack of actual damage, it's actually the movie's
funniest moment, sending the bus flipping
but barely denting the metal.
Man of Steel
Actor Henry Cavill packed on a ton of muscle
for the role, but it's Superman's superhuman
strength that makes him impossible to beat.
Or, when he's dealing with a group of rowdy
bar patrons, impossible to even move.
It's one of the film's most understated gags...
But it causes a problem.
When Clark was almost killed aboard a fishing
vessel earlier in the movie, one of his shipmates
can push him out of the way like any other
human.
The Dark Knight Rises
When you're making a movie about Batman's
last fight, who has time to worry about traffic
lights cooperating with filming?
Fans could probably buy Catwoman speeding
through a red light in Bruce Wayne's stolen
Lamborghini, but the rest of the traffic pretending
it's green makes a production oversight a
lot more likely.
The GCPD become the real heroes of the movie
when they square off against Bane's army in
downtown Gotham.
It's a memorable moment, made even more unforgettable
by the crew member coming out of a subway
station before realizing he's just walked
into the shot.
Luckily, he's missing from the next one.
Ant-Man
If you had a hard time grasping the science
behind Marvel's Ant-Man, you're not alone.
And you're not wrong, either.
The Superhero is made possible by Pym Particles,
allowing a person or object to shrink, but
keep the same amount of mass and energy - just
shrinking the spaces between its atoms.
It makes enough sense, but when you consider
Hank Pym has been walking around with a full
size tank in his pocket, and Darren Cross
lifts a lamb with only two fingers, the science
doesn't add up.
Deadpool
It's a single matchstick from the villain
Angel Dust that helps Wade Wilson escape his
torture at the hands of the movie's villains.
The match is used to ignite and detonate oxygen
tanks, but oxygen itself isn't actually flammable.
Seeing the match burn a bit brighter would
have been scientifically accurate, but...
a lot less exciting.
The Avengers
Since it launched Marvel's shared movie universe,
the Post-Credits scene from the first Iron
Man will probably be the most famous of all
time.
Which means the hilarious mistake in it isn't
going anywhere either.
Look closely: it isn't just Nick Fury waiting
to surprise Tony Stark at the end of the movie,
but the crew member clearly reflected in the
picture frames on the wall.
Once you see it, you'll wonder how you ever
missed it.
The Avengers: Age of Ultron
When the Avengers are rescuing innocent civilians
from Ultron, Thor and Cap team up to violently
throw one woman to safety.
But Cap's powers are even better than fans
realized, since he grabs the woman with BOTH
arms - and still manages to keep them hanging
on the entire time.
He's been holding out on us.
Those are some of the most amazing mistakes
and goofs in our favorite superhero movies,
but which ones have we missed?
Let us know in the comments, and remember
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!